- So I've titled this Control
= Prediction + Engineering.
I think this is the grammar that I use
to think about these sorts of questions.
I have an amazing post-doctoral
associate in my lab
who's here, who I sat down and he said,
"I didn't know you worked
on causal inference."
And I said, "Well, you know,
"it looks like we have a lot
to know about each other,
"but I think we're gonna use the grammar
"of kind of prediction,
which is largely what we use
"in the evolutionary and
bioengineering paradigms,
"which is the ones in which,
"the ones in which I operate today."
Before doing anything else, really,
I wanna acknowledge the
organizers of this meeting,
everybody who supported this.
This is one of the coolest
and most interesting
gatherings I've been at
in my several years at Yale.
I always say that this
institution needs more
kind of renegade, nerd gatherings.
There's not enough, and this
absolutely qualifies as one.
So I appreciate everyone who supported,
and all of you, of course, for attending,
all of the individuals
in my research program,
all the individuals
who've supported this work
in various ways through the years.
And of course, a large
library of mentors, mentees,
former mentees who are now mentors,
people who now support me in various ways.
They've influenced this work
in various ways through the years.
And my newest family,
the Santa Fe Institute,
which has really been important
for integrating this dimension
of my research program,
and further my identity
for asking questions
that are related to what
we're discussing here
at this workshop today.
So I want to make sure
they are acknowledged.
You know, the reason
why I titled the talk,
my title came from some popular writing.
I was actually writing
the article on the top
where I actually introduced this,
really just a conceptual framework
for thinking about how we're thinking
about controlling evolutionary
biology in various settings,
largely in the construction
of biomolecules.
And I came up with this framework,
control equals prediction
plus engineering.
It's really just a, like I said,
it's a conceptual anchor
for how to think about
how we're, the types
of information we need
to be able to control a
complex biological system.
Right, and I kind of use this as an anchor
for the rest of this talk,
but mostly we're gonna be focusing
on the prediction component of this
since that's kind of the one related,
not the same as, but related to causality.
How do I enter these problems?
Well, I mean, I think my
basic science program,
I've been described as a
lot of different things.
I give a talk at many different sorts
of scientific audiences.
So depending on who I'm around
is the way I'm described,
but a computational biologist mostly,
and we use a range of
methods where we use disease
to ask fundamental questions
kind of about the way nature works.
And I think on the flip side,
we use kind of theory in various paradigms
to potentially improve how we think
about disease and epidemics.
But I think there's another component
of my research program,
which is going to be very,
very active here today.
And I think it is an act really
in all areas of my program.
And that's kind of the intersection
between data and culture.
I think this is something that began
as something that I
was doing just because,
but this has actually become
a real technical paradigm
for my work.
And I think it dances very intimately
with some of the other
dimensions of my work.
So you'll be introduced to this as well.
But I think really
there's been a combination
between these identities recently.
Like I said, which is,
and I think really where I land is that
I focus on how interactions
shape constraints
in biological systems.
Whether we're talking
about engineered systems
or we're talking about artificial systems
or informational systems.
I mean, really you can define,
we can define all of them
by what are the guardrails around them?
What are the things that
are actually shaping
how those systems are constructed?
In my sense, the way things evolve,
these interactions shape
molecular evolution.
They constrain how epidemics manifest
and they constrain science in the world,
which is an all in which it is embedded.
So this is really how I can frame,
I call myself an interaction nerd.
I like when I put things together
and I get something surprising
and I kind of use biological systems
to be able to ask those
sorts of questions.
Now, when we think about
what a constraint is,
I think this manifests in
all the talks that we heard.
We heard this outstanding,
just this morning we've heard
about different constraints
and the way they shape
the systems of interest.
Be they cosmological,
be they anthropological,
be they cellular, be they biophysical.
We can think about a lot of ways.
And so this is like one
dimension of constraint
where I mostly live.
I study proteins and I study
kind of protein folding.
And here you have an enzyme.
Dihydrofolate reductase,
basically it catalyzes a
reaction at different rates
and different temperatures.
So in this situation.
Temperature is a context,
which is kind of constraining
what this enzyme can do.
And in my lab, we identify kind
of the way this constrains,
the way it evolves.
It sets the expectations
for the way this sort of protein evolves.
We can think about constraint this way.
If many of you work on the kind
of ecosystem ecology scale,
or if you think about climate change,
or you think about species distribution,
or any kind of really,
even this is in many ways geopolitical.
All right, you can think about forces
operating on this level.
Some of us kind of live in
this level here, me less so.
This is, any New Yorkers in the audience?
This is the Queensbridge.
Okay, good.
This is the Queensbridge houses.
So this is the largest
public housing complex
in the United States now,
and it's home to all my
heroes from growing up.
And I think one of the great question is,
you know, what is it about
neighborhoods like this
that give birth to so many
people gifted with words
in terms of hip hop artists.
And this is something that was
very, very important to me.
We think about this in a lot of contexts.
What is it about this,
these sets of constraints and contexts
that kind of created that opportunity
for that sort of linguistic advancement?
But then of course, this one.
These constraints are tied together.
It's not different than
when we heard about scales.
I think there's resonance
between these things.
There's a relationship between
some of those constraints
we talked about, for example,
like that constraint,
that relates to that constraint.
But this constraint, of course,
in this context, of course,
did not grow out of the ground.
This one came out because
of constraints like this,
historical constraints.
Like they were active
decisions made by homo sapiens
about who could live where,
who could be how you treat certain people
and what have you.
So the point is that all
areas of my research program
and all areas of all the
things we're discussing here
in this, right, with regation
to causation and inference,
they're being shaped by various forces.
And so what I'm gonna
argue is that, right,
the success, if you will,
or the effectiveness of causal inference
and, or in my case, prediction or control
is really gonna be grounded by, right,
our understanding of the way
these sorts of constraints
influence our systems of interest,
our understanding of them,
our ability to parameterize them.
And that really is, right,
that's kind of the framework
that I approach these
sorts of questions with.
And so we'll meet various
components of these
and various actors.
Now, I'm not nearly as
smart enough to study this
and this well enough.
There's people who have
studied this for centuries,
infinitely better than I ever could.
But I have found the
attempt to do so, right,
to them to be the idiot
in the room, right,
when we're reading about
that sort of thing,
to be refreshing,
and it has added to the dimensions
of my work in many ways.
So, like I said, we're
gonna get through a lot.
So we're doing okay?
All right.
So control prediction is engineering.
So again, like I said, right,
these sorts of constraints
are actually shaping
our ability to predict,
and really they're shaping the engineering
and they shape our ability
to control systems,
complex systems of interest.
And today we're gonna talk
about two different systems,
right?
Genetics and evolution.
We got this outstanding talk today
that did a lot of the work for us.
So I can skip a lot of that.
So thank you for that, professor.
And epidemics,
these are both "biological" systems.
And they have many things in common.
So what we're gonna do
is we're gonna kind of talk
about a little bit of a history
of how we think about prediction
and causation in these realms.
Very, very little history.
We're gonna talk about the modern times,
like what are the contemporary issues
and challenges for thinking about these?
And then I'm gonna hopefully end
with a little bit of positivity
with regards to new
ways for thinking about
how we can think about
prediction more carefully.
And both of them,
I'll introduce a new
theorem in the process,
a funny theorem in the process.
So history and genetics and evolution,
we can kind of think about a lot of ways,
a lot of really smart.
David, I don't know how
you feel about this,
but this is kind of one way of.
One way of capturing
the era we've been in.
I know it's, I think the
modern age probably needs it.
We're kind of like, in some ways,
we're in the age of genomics,
in some ways we're in a different era.
But what we're gonna focus on now
is the modern evolutionary synthesis.
We got a really, really great
primer for that earlier.
And I think importantly.
This era is the one
that really transformed
kind of biology into a quantitative field.
Of course, as you know,
everybody who does empirical
science of any kind
has been profoundly
influenced by Fisher's work.
But really it was about the fusion
of these Darwinian and Mendelian schools
and kind of formulated evolution
as a quantitative science
capable of describing and explaining
the process of evolution.
And so pretty much right away
when we got these quantitative tools
to be able to potentially
treat a biological system
like a physical one,
pretty much right away.
People came up with these
new fundamental ways
to describe how populations work.
We were able to describe and understand
what had happened for millennia
with regards to artificial selection
and agriculture and domestication.
So it was really one of the most powerful
sets of understandings that
we've ever come up with,
I think, and I will defend that.
But of course, with that came
false prediction as well.
And it came some errors as well.
And of course, that we can cast
that in the eugenic movement.
The notion that we can take these kind of
discrete principles and apply
them to human population.
So when we think about this,
and I think this is the challenge.
When we're thinking about
how to understand systems
well enough to understand cause and effect
or causal inference or
understand prediction.
There's breakthroughs and
then there's questions
about what we do with those tools.
And then there's kind
of technical misgivings
that oftentimes lead to certain problems.
And we see the signature
for both the beauty
and the problems of this paradigm today.
So, I mean, this is a great
time to be in this profession.
I think we're doing all
kinds of important things
with genomic technology.
You might have saw the
approval of the first CRISPR,
kind of truly CRISPR driven
therapy for sickle cell anemia
that was just recently approved.
So, I mean, it's really one
of the most amazing times
to ever think about living
systems in this way.
And so we can think about
things like genomic prediction
and we think about genetic engineering
in ways we've never been able to.
We can wire organisms mutation by mutation
in order to kind of get
to phenotypes of interest.
But of course, with that
comes things like this.
And I don't know, we had
a conversation over dinner
so I wanna make sure I put this in.
Because this actually,
I don't know how many,
maybe raise hands, anybody seen this film?
All right, I got a big raise back there.
Well, good, I don't have to feel bad.
This is pretty nerdy
what you're gonna see.
So I actually wrote a paper about this
that made the cover of genetics.
And the idea here is
we kind of use the film
to have a conversation about this exactly.
The whole thing is how are
our predictive tools doing?
We use the film to have a
contemporary conversation
about where we are with
this sort of technology.
And we actually review
things like embryo selection.
What are the statistics about it?
How good are we, how good are we not?
And they actually got a
lot of things quite right
in the film 25 years ago.
So again, right, cultural
relics and cultural things
end up being this
important kind of substrate
for us to be able to think
about the contemporary technical issues
when we're thinking about
causation and prediction.
Okay, but of course, there's
many other conflicts.
Right, many, many, many others.
So even things that I participated in
like the precision medicine paradigm,
the notion that we can treat
every single individual here
according to their peculiar biology.
I mean, it's just riddled
with a lot of kind of
technical misgivings.
We've already seen genetic
discrimination happen.
Obviously, some of you are a
part of these conversations
about genetically modified technology.
So these are some of the areas
where despite all these
breakthroughs and excitement,
we have a lot of contemporary
questions, right,
about what it is that we're doing here.
And of course, the rise
of extremism and fascism
and race science, which of
course is another older.
This goes back to eugenics,
but of course, has been reanimated.
So what we talked about here
was kind of this history
of how genetics kind of has thought
about this sort of problem
and some contemporary things
that we should be very, very excited about
and some other things
that we should be very,
very cautious about.
And I think the same thing goes
for how we think about the epidemics.
And of course, you know, long,
long history of epidemics.
I'm gonna capture it in two slides,
but kind of modern public
health as we understand it.
Some of you know this story
about kind of the water pump
and it was cholera and
it was the identification
of the source being a water supply
is the birth of by many
opinions of public health
as we know it today.
And of course, mathematical epidemiology,
which is one of my paradigms,
again, can be traced to many people.
There's a long history going back,
but I think the kind of one
of the modern iterations
that some of us,
I learned they actually
teach in physics here,
which I was very, very happy
to hear in intro physics here.
They actually teach dynamical systems
to the biology majors.
And it's basically this notion
of how you can understand
and mathematize a population
undergoing some kind
of infectious process.
And this goes back to 1927, okay.
So again, long history doing that,
a lot of successes, lots of failures,
but we can kind of animate that now
and what those contentions
and challenges are
with regards to,
'cause the point is when
you model something,
presumably you understand
what its character is
such that you can potentially predict it.
Like that's the point.
You wanna be able to understand
who you need to vaccinate and where,
where you need to intervene
and what have you.
And I think this of course
has been animated here
in case you haven't been paying attention.
And of course, the roles of modeling
and what we were predicting and how
was really one of the central
conflicts of the pandemic era
and remains so.
And I think mathematical
mind was kind of on trial,
if you will, in this sort of way.
And so it had to kind of,
we had to kind of reflect
on what are we modeling?
How are we modeling it?
Are we using the right tools?
What are the assumptions
that we're making.
This ended up being something
very, very important
that was essential.
Now, in the face of this,
I did some mathematical modeling on this,
but most of my work, again,
we're gonna return why I
think this sort of meeting
and why I'm so grateful
for this sort of gathering
is the multidisciplinarity
is not just nominal.
You really actually learn from it.
You learn what the important
questions are from engaging
because I did a little bit of this,
but I did much more of this,
much more public engagement.
I became kind of a misinformation warrior
during the pandemic.
So I did some mathematical,
and what I learned about the pandemic
and the way we engage it is that
there are several challenges
that I think that are
common to both genetics
and epidemiology.
So when you think about
causation and prediction,
I think the ethical is the
technical in some ways.
So I think these are separate paradigms
with separate grammars.
But part of the conversation,
a lot of the things that
we think are ethical
are actually rooted in technical
challenges that we have,
in being able to properly predict
the shape of an epidemic
or being able to properly predict
what the phenotypic
effects are of a mutation
or what's in the genome
or the relationship between
genotype and phenotype.
And, you know, it's rooted in,
we might be really swell people,
but our ideas might be bad.
I mean, in particular
in the genomics context.
You might have good intentions,
and I'm not here to judge
anybody's intentions
with regards to being able to predict
whether or not baby A or B
will get into Yale or not.
You might have good intentions.
But the ideas that you're using
to be able to kind of, you know,
influence that prediction,
of course, might be bad.
And of course, this applies very firmly
to a lot of the conversation
with regards to ethical AI,
right, but I was talking
to someone, I think you,
about timescale yesterday.
The timescale consequences
and effect on accountability,
sometimes the negative
consequences are too downstream
for the people who are, right.
So if I mispredict the
shape of an epidemic
like two years from now,
and I come up with a harmful policy
is that timescale for which
that's wrong and causes harm,
does that match up with
me being held accountable
for my bad decision-making up front.
So this is one of the problems.
There's not a lot of cost
for me getting things wrong
when I'm making these
incorrect predictions,
and that's sure as heck
goes in the genomic context
when you don't see the consequences
for your actions for generations.
So I think there's that challenge
that we have to deal with.
But more than that, are we thinking
about complex biological
systems correctly.
And this is where we'll go next.
I have some kind of frameworks
for how to think about this.
And so you're understanding the role
of constraining context and shaping,
it can really help our predictions.
I think there are frameworks
and understandings
and concepts in both
genetics and epidemics
that can actually help us
kind of wade through this.
One of the things I try to fight through
when I think about these sorts
of complex biological systems
with a lot of different
process of information
is to not be nihilistic.
The goal, the point is not
that everything is hopelessly complicated
and so we shouldn't bother.
Maybe some of you think that.
But like that's not where I live.
I think it's more about understanding
what the specific roles of those contexts.
So we'll talk about these two things.
What are some constraints
that govern complex biological systems?
In genetics, we have gene
by environment interactions.
You might have heard that one.
That one is reasonably popular.
And that is the notion
that you can't really tell
what the consequences of a
gene or a mutation are doing.
You need to know something
about the environment you're in.
I think the second one is
what we'll talk briefly
about today, gene by gene interactions.
It's a concept called epistasis
and it's a little bit odd.
So we'll spend a second there.
With epidemics,
host-parasite interactions.
I think anybody that's ever
been sick knows what that means.
But host-host interactions is the way
that people are interacting,
influence the dynamics
of disease, you bet.
But then there's other social forces
that can interact with how hosts
or interact with other hosts,
and by extension, are
interacting with parasites.
And these are the sorts of
interactions, like I said,
that are actually shaping these
complex biological systems.
And by extension, influence causal change,
and influence predictive, the
possibility of prediction.
Okay, so we'll start with genetics.
Now we'll start with this
concept called epistasis.
It's been called the
dark matter of biology
for the physicists.
Or the dark matter of genetics.
Now what is it exactly?
This is a great colloquial definition
from a mentor and friend, Dan Weinreich,
a theoretical population geneticist.
"The surprise at the phenotype
when mutations are combined
given the constituent
mutation's individual effects."
I know what mutation A does by itself.
I know what mutation B does by itself.
I put 'em together and I
get a whoa, a surprise.
And that's like legitimately what it is.
I have this fun graduate student analogy.
I have two extraordinarily
talented graduate students
in my lab when they combine.
So these are their, is there a pointer?
It's on here.
Oh, yes.
Right, so both of them have, are positive.
This is kind of a, the y-axis
is just how good they are.
So they're extraordinary, both of them.
You put them together, you put
them together experimentally,
right, and you get this,
you get this additive effect.
As in you just add 'em together.
When they're coding together,
you get this extraordinary
kind of non-linear positive interaction,
which means they code
together beautifully.
But when I ask them to
write a paper together,
they actually like have
a negative interaction.
And they get less work done together
than either of them would have
been done individually.
And that's really what we're
talking about with mutations.
I mean, I think they have
these sorts of different
interaction effects between mutations.
Now, why is this important?
I mean, it's just completely
rewires how we think
about the importance of the
individual mutation or gene
in dictating phenotype.
If all your genotes,
if all your phenotypes
depend on interactions between genes,
and we're talking about 20,000 and 50,000
and 100,000 genes, then the problem,
I mean, astronomical is too small
to think about how quickly this
combinatorial explosion
creates a mess here.
Well, unless we have some
tools for this crowd.
Yeah, we have, the point of this is just,
we have a whole host of statistical tools
to be able to resolve out
higher-order interactions.
I think, I look around the room,
and look, you all have them.
In fact, we've borrowed this
from theoretical computer science.
This is the Walsh-Hadamard transform,
which comes from noise stuff
in engineering and computer science.
But we now apply it to
how we can resolve out
and come up with the basic algebra
for how we can resolve out
how epistatic interactions
are occurring between genes.
But again, this nihilism question.
Is this a nihilistic understanding?
If everything has to interact
with everything else,
isn't that kind of a hopeless feeling.
But thankfully, there's some new concepts
with regards to epistasis
that I think give us rhyme and reason,
and that's called global epistasis.
This basically says that
there are fundamental rules
governing how those interactions
between those graduate students happen,
such that I can potentially predict them.
So even though they're nonlinear,
and they feel surprising when it happens,
there's actually an underlying physics
of kind of interacting information,
and this is pioneered by Alvaro Sanchez,
my close colleague, and
we've done this work.
We've done a bunch of
work on this recently.
So they also often
follow systemic patterns
that enable predictability,
and this kind of changes our relationship
with a concept that would
otherwise be nihilistic.
We now have this understanding
that, wow, we can actually
do something about this
to understand this phenomenon,
and now this is being animated
all across kind of genetics and genomics
to add rhyme and reason to phenomenon
that seem to undermine predictability.
So, again, global epistasis suggests
that there's fundamental rules
for these sorts of interactions,
such that they can be predicted,
and we'll kind of know not to make them,
write papers together, but they.
Now, shifting to the epidemic context.
We talked about host-parasite
interactions, HOSO.
We're gonna talk about
the sorts of constraints
that influence them, and
what are some different ways
we can think about prediction
and causation in this system, all right?
So one of the things that I've studied
is the kind of mathematical
and computational models
of hepatitis C virus.
We call this the silent
epidemic for a bunch of reasons,
right, having to do with
the people it affects,
it's people who inject drugs,
and how, like, the natural
history of the disease
kind of can make it
challenging to understand,
but nonetheless, it's extremely important.
And so what we did is we actually took,
we created a mathematical
model that if you look at,
if you think about a disease
that's spread by people
who are sharing drug paraphernalia,
it has features in common with
a vector-borne disease.
This is exactly what
we did mathematically.
We basically, right,
published here in 2019,
but something very important
happened in this work.
When we were doing this work,
I found myself in Reddit forums
of people who were users,
right, because I'm trying
to understand some things
about the way that the
disease is transmitted,
and in that, I kind of,
I got very, very guilty
'cause I said, "Here,
I'm trying to mathematize
"something with all of this social import.
"This is something that's
really, really affecting people."
Okay, now, right, part of the reason
why this became important mathematically
is I began to think and learn more
about the way social forces
are actually crafting the thing
that I'm trying to mathematize.
So that ends up being a
serious and important dimension
for how we're thinking about modeling
and predicting the shape
of these epidemics.
I can't possibly understand
anything about disease
if I'm not engaged with the forces
that are actually influencing the host.
So again, right, a reason why to engage
these different disciplines.
And of course, there's
other social forces,
and I began to work on this.
I've worked on this, right,
how kind of policy
regarding prison influences
the dynamics of a pandemic
in multiple dimensions.
So what we're seeing here is, right,
in the context of epidemiology was, right,
I'm interested, I have a complex system
composed of all of these elements,
and I wanna know how to predict it.
We can think about
causation in this system,
and we're identifying
all of these constraints
that influence what those
predictions will be.
And this paper here is
really one of my favorite,
and it's admittedly by
two good friends of mine,
but I think it's one of
the most important papers
I think I've read in
epidemiology in quite some time.
And they introduced
this notion from physics
called permutation entropy, right,
which kind of has this other life,
but they apply it to
the case of epidemics.
And this is what they say.
Here's the model that we
did for hepatitis C virus.
And so we don't, you know, for those,
one of the innovations that we did
is we modeled needles
as their own population,
and so we can actually
think about what happens
when you take needles out of a population,
for example, with a safe injection sites,
or with needle exchange,
these sorts of public health interventions
that allow you to actually directly deal
with the problem of needles.
That was one of the kind
of conceptual innovations
to this mathematical model.
What this paper says is that
if you wanna predict the
shaping of an epidemic, okay,
the problem is the
parameters themself change
as the epidemic is happening.
And so you are hopeless
in trying to predict
an epidemic past a few days.
And of course, it'll depend on disease,
it'll depend on.
But it introduced kind of this idea
that it really is a fruitless venture
to try to come up with a universal,
long-term predictive algorithm.
It doesn't work that way
because the parameters are
changing too, too fast.
And I think this is the innovation here.
And I think it's had a big effect on me
because this is the sort of thing.
It's not that we can't predict,
it's that perhaps we should be changing
what our goals are for prediction.
It's not that we can't
understand causal chains,
it's how far apart they are
when we're talking about the actors
and their consequences in
epidemiological systems.
And so this is what we
mean about prediction.
Now, we talked about this
in various frameworks.
We talked about this in genetic systems,
the sorts of things
that both undermine
prediction in genetics,
but potentially, right,
there's utility here.
The global epistasis framework
potentially allows us to predict.
In the context of epidemics,
we can talk about something similar.
I think the permutation
entropy framework helps us.
And what I'll leave is with
something very, very, right,
with a concept.
This is my son and he's a toddler.
Anybody that's ever been
around a toddler knows
predicting what your child is gonna be
is a very, very important,
like that's kind of part
of what being a parent is.
I have a prediction that he's
gonna live with me at 30,
but you know, by the way he
acts now, but you never know.
Now, as useful as it would
be for me to be able to,
this is very important,
as useful as it would be
able to be for me to predict
that he's gonna be quarterback
for the University of Michigan,
it's actually much more useful
for me to be able to predict
when he'll be able to nap tomorrow.
So the notion that a
long-term prediction is better
or holistic is better is just not true.
I think we should learn to be, right,
somewhat satisfied or in fact,
goal shift to tuning our expectations
in particularly with regards to time scale
for our predictions.
And that is, right, if we have
very, very, very, very strong
predictive ability for tomorrow,
that's actually actionable,
that's not actually any
less rigorous technically,
and I think it completely
changes how we think
about a lot of these
complex biological systems.
Yeah, anyway.
Great.
(audience applauding)
- Very interesting to point out
that that time scale over
which predictions are made
are sort of fundamentally relevant
because in public policy
frameworks and contexts,
you know, you need to make decisions
and it's fine to say for
astronomical systems,
I can predict two galaxies that will merge
in 10 to the seven years or whatever.
So yeah, thanks for
bringing that into focus.
Questions?
- Great.
Thanks so much for your very rich talk.
Yeah, I just wanted to maybe
think together a bit more
just about constraints
and the role they play
'cause it seems to me there's kind of,
so some people just think of constraints
as like additional causes or stable causes
that you haven't measured.
I guess my suspicion has always been
that they're much richer.
That's not just something
like causal variable
that you could have intervened
on that you didn't include,
but can be something, I mean,
we have historical
constraints or long patterns
or sometimes these timescale
dependent behaviors,
it really feels more like a
fundamental characterization
of the system and there's
no translatability.
So I was just actually trying,
I'm really trying just to open
up a conversation about it.
If you have a thought about
how to model constraints,
is it just, yeah.
- Yeah, no, no, thank you for that.
I mean, I think, you know,
take a problem like antibiotic
resistance evolution,
which is something that I think about.
It's a complex problem.
It's an evolutionary problem.
It's a molecular problem.
It's a protein problem.
We've studied that problem
from the Angstrom scale.
When you think about
kind of the likelihood
of evolving something like that,
this is where
multidisciplinarity is essential.
It's not just like fun to talk to people.
Half the problem is people's
willingness to take drugs
on a certain schedule.
So if you are not,
that is a constraint
that the system, right,
that is actually dictating the pace
and the direction of evolution
of antimicrobial resistance.
So I think I like your
definition in the sense of,
it's all, I mean, it's all of the things
that we don't need to know all of them.
But we need to know the ones
that meaningfully influence
the dynamics that we are trying to predict
and/or establish causal chains between.
So that's how I think about constraints.
And I think the challenge is the silos.
Either we're not trained
to think very, very broadly
about some of these other dimensions
or we're unwilling to do so,
or we don't have people
who bring them together
in this sort of way.
And I think this is why a lot of my work,
I've gained tremendously from being able
to open up that dimensionality.
- Thank you.
Shyam.
- The problem of prediction
in sociobiological systems like epidemics.
Where there's a feedback loop,
prediction itself can cause conditions
that will make that prediction untrue,
which is very different from
pure physical systems on.
- More than anything.
I mean, I think that's true, we see that.
- What do we do on,
how do we deal with the
problem of prediction
in social systems?
- No, I mean, again, I'm not a,
believe it, I'm the not negative one
about these sorts of
things in a lot of rooms.
Yeah, I mean,
mathematical modeling has
got a lot of things right.
There are a lot of conditions
that it actually was able
to properly characterize
or understand.
And I think that is because
we had a proper understanding
of what the constraints
were in that system.
So I think we have an understanding
of kind of what the way that
people were interacting,
and we understand what
the constraints are.
I think we have a lot
of successful iterations
where we've predicted the trajectory
of epidemics quite well.
So it's not a hopeless task.
It is just one where our
expectations need to be modified
by our understanding of
what the constraints are.
That's what I would say.
- I mean, and I guess it also behooves
like continual updating of predictions.
So it's not even made a prediction,
it's out there.
It's a very live process.
Eduardo and then Junal.
- Thank you, Brandon.
I think I'm gonna follow
up on the conversation
we had yesterday overnight.
What makes me think a lot of,
we keep talking about understanding,
we keep talking about knowledge.
And when I hear colleagues like you
and other colleagues who are
much more at the boundaries
between applied and very
translational science,
more and more I'm asking myself,
who needs to understand,
who needs to know?
Because at one level, I
feel like what are the time
where we feel like every
citizen has to understand
how the vaccine works?
Are we gonna expect to
understand how that bridge
that I'm gonna cross with a car was built?
And so I think it's creating
a lot of social issues,
confusion, problems that have
really, I mean, affect us all.
What are your thoughts on do,
I mean, it's thinkable
that at so many levels,
we don't need everyone to understand.
I mean, it used to be that
I would go to the doctor.
I mean, you did a pregnancy test.
You were not asking
how does the urine work
with the strip, et cetera.
You assume you were
pregnant, you moved on.
And my worries is that,
again, in the talking
and being those of us, some of us push
to do more and more outreach
and it's getting all very confusing
and people don't know they're listening
to the peer reviewed, to the peer review
or a version of the paper.
Either listen to the scientist,
either listen to the scientist
educator slash citizen.
And I really think that
there's some positive aspects
to the science being siloed.
We can, everyone feels
like they need to know
and understand, but not
everyone has spent 30 years
looking at disease transmission.
- Yeah, I mean, my opinion
is, that's a tough one.
So things are easier when they're siloed
and less democratic in that way.
When there's less input
from the public, you know?
- Well, at least there's a partition
between experts and non-experts.
- Yeah, when there's a partition between,
I mean, it's easier, we
don't have to answer.
My job would be easier if I did not feel
like I was compelled to communicate it
with my grandmother.
I would just be able to do the science
and talk to you and talk to you.
Unfortunately, that's not how I think,
that's not where I think my job is.
So I don't agree with that.
I'm actually deeply
pro-democratization of science.
I want a future where citizens
can actually participate
in the scientific process.
Now, we're a long way from
that, that's utopian, perhaps.
- No, but also highly problematic.
Because the sources of
getting information now
and disinformation and misinformation.
- But it's problematic now, even within.
It's not like we're doing the job well
as professional scientists.
There's misinformation now
within professional science.
There's gatekeeping within
professional science.
There's discrimination
within professional science.
So I think we need to
stop looking at ourselves
as a paradigm for the way that it works,
'cause it doesn't.
It works for us, and we're doing fine.
But I know a lot of people that aren't.
- But the way we think of democracy
is not having 300 million
people voting 24/7
for every single thing that we do.
I mean, that's a referendum,
it's not a democracy.
In a democracy, I used
to defer to my doctor
who, in some way, I decided he knows.
And my dad told me, "You
ride the bike this way."
I didn't decide to go
figure it out myself.
So there has to be some
trust in those people.
- But my mother has faced discrimination
in the medical community often.
And if she did not have me there
to ask questions of
the experts growing up,
she would have had a
shorter life, frankly.
So that's my point.
Yeah, it's easier for
me to trust the person
with the expertise, and that
would have made it quicker,
and that would have made it easier,
and the physician might have felt better
about not having to answer a question
from a poor black woman,
but the right thing to do was for him
to answer the questions that she had
about what the decision was being made.
- Yeah, I mean-
- And of course,
it's easier the other way, but it's wrong.
- Yeah, no, absolutely.
And I think part of the issue, really,
is with the openness comes
certain kinds of risks.
So when we are not yet done
finishing our understanding
or analysis, and we
are sort of in process,
that is now open to the public.
And I think that creates
a lot of possibilities.
So I think we have to think very hard
about how to democratize
and how to open up
the processes of science
as inference, really.
I mean, 'cause that's what the
public really wants to know.
How are you arriving at this conclusion
when you're giving me a directive?
I think Samantha put it
really nicely, right,
that even if you give
the right information,
decision-making is really complex.
People may not actually use the,
they may just go for the simplest version
of the information that you can provide,
which may not be fully accurate.
- I agree with both of you intensely,
and then also have worked on
discrimination in medicine,
which will lead to new fears for everyone.
Basically, if you tell your doctor things
that they disagree with,
they'll like you less.
So great.
- I've seen it happen.
- Great news.
But for me, it's more
about this expectation
that we should all be
informed about everything,
which is just humanly impossible.
You can't read up about
every single decision
you wanna make, and that
shouldn't be an expectation
we create for people.
- But I feel like every
time we talk about that,
we turn the dial up to,
everybody doesn't need to understand
everything in the universe.
And that's not, there's a lot of levels
between where we are now and that.
Like, what I learned in the vaccine era
is people just wanted
to know how it worked.
Once they learned how it worked,
they went and took the vaccine.
I get calls to this day,
I get emails to this day.
Something I said on a podcast
got their whole family vaccinated.
'Cause I just took the time to explain,
like it's not everybody
wants to have access
to everything ever, and we got this,
we're gonna be fighting for seats
because everybody in the community
who thinks they understand
what causation means,
that's not the reality.
And in fact, the reality that we create,
the idea we've created has
created the war on science.
The silos of, has actually
created the substrate
for society to distrust science.
So we need to completely
break that and prove that.
- And the question is whether
the inferential process
should be in full public view,
how much of it should be in public view
or whether it should be
in public view or not
is a big sort of question to debate.
Janelle.
- To quickly, I wanna go back
to the point that Shawn made
that it's a very different setting where
knowledge itself is androgenous
that knowledge is changed,
what knowledge you have
and the way the knowledge
feeds into the system
is affecting the system.
That means that you can't
stabilize the system
as an object of knowledge
because everything that you know about
is gonna change the system,
very different setting
from traditional system
and deeply important in exactly the realms
that you're talking about.
- Thank you for that.
- Yeah, Tim.
- This is just a short comment
in terms of I understand this discussion
and there's certainly a big problem
with communicating science
and motivating people
to behave the right way.
And to say a lot of the
problem arises from within,
but let's not ignore that
the fossil fuel industry
undertook a billion-dollar
campaign to misinform people
that the tobacco industry undertook
billion-dollar campaigns
to misinform people
and with the intentional effect
to undermine faith in science.
So I don't know that we should blame our,
I mean, we have our
bits of blame, but yeah.
- My question is what do we do?
That's my question.
- Yeah.
- So is the answer that because
the fossil fuel industry
flooded the industry of billions
and misinformed the public
and I work on topics related to that,
that I'm not culpable
to do anything about it?
Is that the answer?
- No.
You do something about it.
We should be the ones going
to war with these people.
This is what happened with eugenics.
- Right.
- I'm not, I just, the
other option is unconscious.
- But I think Tim is absolutely right
that they're having established playbooks.
So at some level, we have
the advantage post-hoc
of knowing how these misinformation
and disinformation campaigns
can work and have worked
and in what ways they are successful.
And I think the, I mean, I
really like the various threads
that have come up.
It is a conundrum.
If we are able to show and
reveal as expert scientists
or people working with data sets
and inferring from data sets,
whatever be those data sets,
even if that process is fully demystified,
it's unclear because you have
these other outside forces
that are sort of banging at the door.
So the question is, given
that is the reality,
is talking about how we
relate effects and causes
and how we arrive at decisions
and how individuals then
incorporate that information
and make decisions, it's
a very complex space.
But I think we all share responsibility
to do something about it.
- Okay, one, two, and three.
I wanna go to coffee, so I
wanna be attentive to that.
- Yes, thank you.
This is a fascinating conversation.
And at the expense of
opening a can of worms.
- Better be a small can.
- Very, very small can.
Very small can called AI.
And my question is,
would it, if and when we have trustworthy,
reliable, robust products and services,
AI products and services,
will that help democratize science?
For example, your mother would have,
instead of asked you and took
you with her to the doctors,
she could have had her phone
and asked, you know, an
AI specialized product.
What do I do with the doctor?
What do I tell the doctor?
- I'll just end it here by saying,
I find myself oddly pro-technology
in a lot of these conversations,
relative to my friends.
Having seen, when you've
seen disinformation
happen in person, you don't,
I'm just not sure that that's a,
I'm not sure that the
algorithmization of it is worse.
- Right, but I mean, the question is-
- I'm not sure, I'm not convinced.
- No, but Brandon, but if the algorithm
has been arrived at with biased-
- Of course, totally right.
- It's gonna be no better.
- No, no, no, totally right.
I'm just, I just don't have
faith in people like that.
- Right.
(laughing)
So, I had a question there.
Quick question.
- [Attendee] I can bring
it up at the coffee hour.
- Okay, great, okay.
- Thank you all.
- Okay, maybe we just wrap
it up and head out to coffee.
(audience applauding)